okay so a little bit about me my
background is in integrated science
physics and math I went to grad school
for physics but did research in
computational neuroscience and at grad
school I had to I was exposed to a lot
of machine learning techniques after
graduating I've worked in science
education and a few tech companies and
currently I'm a data scientist at [ __ ]
gig and if you want to hear more about
shift gig you should come to my other
talk on Sunday ok so I don't know how
many of you guys are familiar with PI
mc3 it's a Markov chain Monte Carlo
sampling library and some of the main
features are that allows you to do
probabilistic programming which I'm sure
a lot of you are already familiar with
especially if you were at the
pomegranate talk this morning the way I
like to think about it is that it allows
us to treat our parameters in our
regression problems as a rising from
distributions rather than just from
point estimates so this allows us to do
things like insert prior knowledge into
the model and give us some idea of the
error of our point estimates of the
different parameters you can use it for
Bayesian statistical modeling model
fitting it's written in Python and PI
mc3 usually has cutting-edge sampling
algorithms and variational inference
techniques ok so a question I'm sure
anyone who's familiar with x III or PI
Stan will have is why did you choose PI
C 3 it's because PI M C 3 is written in
Python that is the only reason I didn't
want to learn Stan okay
some of you may already be familiar with
PI MC 2 pi M C 3 is still in beta so if
you're uncomfortable with beta software
you might want to consider using PI MC 2
because it is a bit older though it
doesn't always have the newest sampling
techniques built into it but it is a lot
more stable so I initially started
working with PI MC 2 but had a lot of
trouble getting my models to converge
things were taking like three weeks I
was totally throwing off my sprints so I
switched to PI MC 3 so I've been a lot
happier with
but there's definitely you're gonna find
bugs in pi MC 3 the developers are super
nice though and they respond really
quickly if you open issues on github or
email them any of that stuff okay so
this is what I'm planning on covering
just setting up a basic model in PI MC 3
sampling from your model obviously
that's what you're gonna want to do
predicting new data if you have say a
test set or a new set of data saving a
trace from your models so that you can
use it later and that's usually
specifically in the case you might need
to make an API call dear model and you
might want to be predicting one data
point okay so the specific models I'm
gonna go over our linear regression
hierarchical linear regression or linear
model and logistic regression and
hierarchical logistic regression
so obviously you probably wouldn't use
pi mc3 for just basic linear regression
you'd use scikit-learn or something
easier but this is mostly just to show
you the PI MC 3 syntax and this will
allow you to build build up model more
complicated models okay any questions
about that outline alright cool
let's go hopefully you guys managed to
download some stuff um if not hopefully
the Wi-Fi will start working for you
soon ok let's see if I can switch over
to the notebook ok can you guys see that
okay hmm one downside is I cannot see it
because I didn't mirror so hold on while
I try and fix that
huh
yay okay I can see it now - all right um
so if you manage to get the repo
downloaded and everything um the
notebook I'm going through is QuickStart
guide with errors there's another
version without the errors in it in case
you want a reference for the future and
then there's a couple of other examples
I forgot to take out so they're yours
now one is a linear hierarchical example
and one is logistic regression those
examples are already inside the Quick
Start Guide with errors
okay so first obviously there's some
imports we want PI M C 3 times C 3 uses
Theano Tiano is the back end doesn't
know how to pronounce that all right
they all know it is and obviously we'll
use a few different libraries as well so
hopefully if all your setup worked that
should work
you can ignore this because I'll explain
in a second um some other stuff I make
it I like making my figures gigantic so
everyone can read the text ok so first
up is linear regression I set up the
notebook in such a way that you should
be able to adapt it to your real data
one of the problems I had when I was
going through a lot of the examples that
exists online is that the examples are
very specific to like a set number of
features and set number of feature names
they weren't really generalizable so
this is meant to be a very generalizable
example so you specify the number of
features so in this case I said 10 if
you have 100 if you have two you can
change it to whatever you want and then
I'm just saying the number of observed
data points is a thousand pretty basic
um so we're doing linear regression so y
equals alpha plus beta x so we're gonna
choose random values for alpha and beta
which is here and then we're gonna
create some fake predictor data and then
we're going to try and you
is pi mc3 to figure out the alphas and
betas alright so here I'm just
calculating the the fake data and
throwing in a little bit of noise okay
so now we'll get to the first time see
three start so with a with PI MC 3 the
first thing you have to do is
instantiate a model and it's
conveniently called model and once you
have your model you can use a with
statement and then specify some things
about your model so we obviously want to
have a parameter for alpha and we're
gonna say that it's normally distributed
you can give it a name alpha and then
you can specify the mean and then you
can either specify the standard
deviation or the precision you can use
either one they're called Sigma R tau
and here's the formula in case you
didn't know this is a slight difference
from pi mc2 and pi in situ I think you
had to use tau I don't I thought
everyone use standard deviations and
then finally you specify the shape or
size we're gonna do the same thing with
the betas except for this time we know
we want to have one beta for each of the
features I'm gonna throw in a little bit
of noise and then we're going to add up
the data I calculate the Y values so
here you can see where I'm throwing in
actual data X train all right
and then we are throwing all that inside
another normal distribution and we're
saying that the observed data is the
fake data that I created before so
hopefully that makes sense
alright so then you can run it so I ran
this notebook yesterday morning and then
I ran it again today and there wasn't an
error and in the last 16 hours somebody
submitted a pull request that fixed this
error that I was first gonna tell you
about so there used to be a problem with
strings and unicode's where they would
give you this super useless error saying
that they needed a string but got alpha
or something like that
is really confusing and I spent a couple
hours on it because I'm not a software
engineer and then I finally went to the
director of back-end engineering and
he's like oh it's a unicode byte string
thing looks like what the hell is that
but you don't need to worry about it
anymore so it should work but if you're
wondering why I cast everything as byte
streams it's because I'm using Python 2
7 and I needed to do that to get the
code to work and the reason I was
breaking before is because I was working
in an environment that somebody else had
set up and they had put in this from
future import Unicode literals
and I wasn't aware of that and so I was
messing everything up but not your
problem anymore because it was just
fixed so convenient ok so here you can
see it still works with Unicode or white
strings all right um so now that we have
the model set up we want to actually
sample from it so you can do that with
another with statement you can set this
step which is the sampler so in this
case I'm using the nut sampler so you
just say what the sampler is and then
you just tell you just sample just press
the sample so it might take a little
while but hopefully it'll come through
any questions while this is running no
okay awesome all right so you get this
nice little progress bar if you had more
samples it would take longer you can see
it's done and so one thing people like
to do is have a burn in period with
their samples a lot so if you want to
have a burning period you can just index
on the trace however much you want your
burning period to be so it's pretty easy
and they have this nice function called
trace plot which will plot all of your
variables for you so you can see here
the distribution of the alpha samples
the sample values over time same thing
with the betas and the noise so it looks
like it's you know relatively converged
pretty good there's also a summary
function will just spit out a
description of all these things that
you've created
so here's alpha we can see
the mean of the distribution the
standard deviation mister quantiles
and the same thing for all the betas
which is pretty good so here we can go
back yeah um well there's a few I think
analytical tests usually I check to see
if the if the distributions are really
pointed like these betas are so it seems
like they're centered around one point
if you looked at it before you had done
much of the sampling it would be really
spread out and won't be as pointed and
here on the other side you can see how
the sample value is changing over time
if you were looking at it if I didn't do
the burnin period you would most likely
see something where the alphabet and you
started at some random starting point
and then move down slowly moved it would
jump around and slowly move down so
whatever the real value is I think
there's some other tests and things you
can do as well yeah of course um all
right so since we simulated this data we
know what that the answer is so we can
check so alpha was negative 0.5 1 so if
we go back up to this summary we see the
model found they give 0.5 to it's
probably good enough for this tutorial
if you need more precision you can spend
your time fixing your model working on
different samplers whatever you want to
do same thing with the betas if we go
look they seem like they're heading in
the right direction at least ok so
that's linear regression um most of the
time though you're not gonna be making
fake data and trying to fit it I don't
really know anyone who has that job but
good for you if you do so we'll use some
data from psycheon
the Boston housing data I know people
are tired of it probably but it's very
easy to get ok so most of you probably
have used scikit-learn so you know you
can load up these different data sets
they've just
options features and test and target
values and things like that so we'll put
them into a data frame I assume most
data scientists use data frames pandas
dataframes so much so that we had a
tutorial on it this morning so you think
that would be a really easy thing
we'll make the columns of future names
and for this example I'm casting some of
the variables two boolean types this
chasse is a boolean of like whether the
house is near the Charles River which is
the thing in Boston I guess so it's a
boolean variable it's true or false this
should not be controversial but as
you'll see you later it is okay so I'll
train it I'll split it into Train test
set
we'll do some linear regression with
scikit-learn just to you give us a
baseline so it's like 75% accurate fine
there's only for two data points so now
we'll do the same thing with pine c3 so
if we will call it earlier when I tried
to pronounce Theano the ATO is the back
end of pi and c3 one thing you can do is
have your inputs and outputs to your
model be shared variables and this
allows you to easily switch out
different sets so in this case we can
first put in the training set and then
later we can change the value of these
shared variables to the testing set and
we don't have to recreate the whole
model each time so we'll make it as the
training set and then we'll have the
same type of model that we had earlier
so just basically a regression so we
have an alpha you have the betas with
the model input and the observed is the
model output okay oh look we got an
error who would have thought that would
happen all right
so as tensor error variable type feel
must be a tensor type have any of you
guys seen this before
do any of you know what it means no
neither do I so I spent a few hours
working on this and you get in you run
into the
these weird errors a lot with pi MC 3 I
assume because they Anna was underneath
it and after a few hours and days of
working on this I finally found some
solutions that will let you get past
these errors I have no idea if these are
the correct solutions or why they work
so if any of you know that come talk to
me afterwards but this will at last at
least let you keep working on your
projects so there's a problem with data
frames for some reason pandas dataframes
don't work in pi MC 3 bottles no idea
why so you can turn them into numpy
arrays and then things mostly seem to
work oh wait no it didn't uh yeah look
and now we got the exact same error same
error even though it's a different
problem so this is another frustration
with the ATO and pi mc3 I think this is
a lot of why people give up on pi MC 3
this doesn't make any sense to me why
we're getting the same error uh but it
turns out boolean's don't work either so
cast your boolean's as integers okay
then I'm obviously doing something wrong
with pandas Shh um little try again
alright no it doesn't matter what order
you do these two things whether you
change it to an integer or turn the data
frame into numpy array first you'll
still get those same two errors I don't
really understand why okay so now we'll
do it again we cast the boolean as an
integer I'm casting the X data as an
umpire array and we get another error
this time it's attribute error shared
variable object has no attribute shape
did any of you notice something that you
thought I might have I should have done
differently
No so the thing I didn't do this time is
I didn't cast why as an umpire ray so
remember I said data frames don't work
this is also a data frame however we're
getting this new interesting error why I
don't know
so both both the shared variable error
and this variable type field must be a
tensor type can be solved by turning
your data frames into an umpire array
it's not clear to me why that works why
you get two different errors something
about Theano
so you can get different arrays
depending on what's wrong with your data
frame I don't know why okay so this time
I did everything right
the boolean yeah so what Oh Sharon um
it's a variable type in Theano that you
can where you can change the value later
on so you can you can first set it up
with like your training data and then
you can later go on and set the value to
be your testing data and you don't have
to recreate your whole model I don't
know anything deeper about it okay so
hopefully the sampler will start so
again we have this with model your model
name block and then we'll tell it to
sample again if you don't specify a
sampler pie mc3 will choose the best one
for your variable types so I think I've
gotten nuts like almost every single
time but you can specify different
things or let it choose for you okay any
questions does anyone have any idea why
these errors King
hmm no you can have floats and in sin
the same array and it's fine oh I see
under the hood
I see okay cool well now you know did
you have a question mm-hmm well we're
sampling so we're not getting a point
estimate we're getting a distribution um
and I will go over what you can do with
that distribution right now okay so this
one trained more or less something weird
is happening with one of the betas I
don't really know why it's happened
every time but the other ones seem to
have converged and since this is not
real data I don't care that much so
again we can look at this trace you can
see the mean and standard deviation and
now if we want to we can compare with
the scikit-learn point estimates so here
we can see the intercept is 38 which is
not the mean here 26 so we're getting a
slightly different value but the beta is
all look like they're going in the right
direction so now though we can score our
model and come up and see how it
compares to the secular and clinic
linear regression so again I'm going to
cast this boolean as an integer and
so now you can use the shared variables
and just replace them with the testing
set so here you just use you take your
variable name and do you set value
casting them is numpy arrays again and
then you can sample from the posterior
and use those to use for your data yeah
but different than one um well the way I
think about it I'm not the best to
explain these is that instead of just
coming up with one single value for your
parameters you're coming up with a
distribution for your parameters you
have some idea of how good your estimate
is and how how much spread there is so
you could come up with a really you
could come up with a point estimate
that's actually not that good because
the standard deviation is really large
and similarly you can put in prior
knowledge that you have so for example
if you know that one of the parameters
is positive for because you have outside
knowledge you can put that into your
model directly does that it's your
question the internet probably knows -
yeah
uh all right what was the first part of
your question
um yeah on which both sides okay um so
the left side are just histograms
distributions so these are the actual
values
so alpha the mean is like 25 and then on
the y axis is frequency
well that's after you've run the trace
it you have to look at it to figure out
if it's converged you're done the right
side is sample number on the x axis and
sample value so it's sort of like it's
the same data but you sort of turned on
a different axis so basically you're
looking for it to be sort of going
towards the same value because you're
sampling it's always gonna have some
noise but you want it to sort of be
circling the same value over time you
wouldn't want it to see it like moving
around a lot but you'll see that at the
beginning while it's trying to find the
best bin
you tell me all right awesome thank you
this is a group talk now okay um cool so
the sampling the posterior sampling
finished we're using the R to score from
scikit-learn and we see it's at like
seventy five percent accuracy and if we
go back up
I think scikit-learn was also at like
seventy five percent so we're doing
about the same which makes sense because
it's linear regression so it'd be really
weird if we didn't get the same results
of it more questions it wasn't the same
the the overall accuracy was the same
well they're both linear regression but
one is just a point estimate and one is
it using a distribution for the
intercept all right so hierarchical
linear regression so this is something
as far as I can tell the scikit-learn
doesn't do as easily but pi mc3 does it
really easily so hopefully some of you
guys know what a chola mess are if not
maybe you'll understand this um so again
i tried to make this really general
purpose so first we're gonna set up the
number of categories in this case it's
four but it could be however many you
want the number that we're observing for
category which gives us the number
observed in the number of features so
then when you just set up a list of all
the categories we're gonna simulate the
features again we're gonna choose random
sorry I'm just gonna start the sampling
so it starts we're gonna choose random
values for the alphas and betas and then
we're gonna make the same data and just
throw in a little bit of noise does that
make sense to everyone okay cool
so again we're gonna set up a PI mc3
model because this is an h LM we're
saying that the alphas and the beta's
are drawn from some parent distribution
which I'm denoting mu alpha and mu beta
all right and so this is what
makes it hierarchical right they're all
sharing some information so we can just
do the same thing as with linear
regression and estimate these parameters
as well so we're saying that this mu
alpha is also normally distributed it
has some has a standard deviation
associated with it I just did it as
uniform same thing with the beta and now
when we get to the the alphas and the
beta's
instead of saying that they're mean 0
and standard deviation whatever I said
before now we say that their mean is
drawn from these hyper parameters Mu
Alpha Sigma Alpha and new Beta Sigma
Beta and now we don't just have one
alpha we have one alpha per category all
right and same thing with the betas we
have we have a matrix that is the number
of categories by the number of features
and now we have to put in a Theano
constant for this list of what category
they are alright it's around some noise
again and now when we set up the data we
want to make sure we're choosing the
correct alphas and betas for that
category so that's why we're indexing
here on C alright does that make sense
to everyone all right I can see by your
confused looks that it does great ok
all right so here's another fun fact
I'll throw in for you you don't have to
use with model block instead you can
just specify what model you want to be
sampled by model equals so I think I did
it both ways throughout the tutorial
that was an accident that I noticed
afterwards okay so we can do the same
thing and plot these variables you'll
see me doing the same things over it
over again all right so we have some it
looks like things have converged looks
pretty good and we can look at this tray
summary again but now we have the mu
alpha and new beta data in there as well
and we can go ahead and
check what our real values are um so the
alphas aren't exact but it looks like
they're heading in the right direction
I'm sure we could do things to make it
better but since this is fake data I
don't really see the point okay
questions about that so this is the
alphas so there's four categories so
there's four alphas this time so each of
these is one of the alphas yes yeah and
same with the betas there should be four
categories times three features okay
cool all right um so now we can do
logistic regression it'll be very
similar to linear regression so we're
gonna set up the same thing we're gonna
specify whatever features we want the
number of observed and then choose
random their values for the alphas and
the beta's okay um yeah so one thing I'm
gonna do now is make it so that one of
the data points is done as you might
guess this will set us up for an error
later okay so how many of you guys have
used add V or have heard of it
one variational inference some of you
okay so add V is a new variational
inference technique I think it's
automatic differentiation variational
inference it's a very new technique
developed by statisticians and it can
you can think of it as a black box that
does parameter estimation for you which
is awesome because as a data scientist I
don't necessarily want to know all the
math details so times III added it a
couple of months ago I think it's coming
to PI Stan soon but it's not there yet
but it's super fast and you can use the
the parameter estimate that you get out
of AD me as the start to a sampler or
you can just use them by themselves all
right oh look at this we got a bunch of
not a number of very early values so
this happens if you try and run ad V on
any data that has any Nan's or
infinities in it so if we just change it
back it will hopefully start running
okay so you can read more about what ad
V does but basically it's another
algorithm that has to converge over time
it's doing another type of sampling and
you're looking for something called the
elbow so it's this curve that hopefully
bends and straightens out and when it's
sort of converges like that you know
that it's done which is nice so they
have some easy ways to plot that data
okay so with ad V you're also getting an
estimate of the distribution so you can
sample from that distribution the same
way we were sampling from the other
distributions so here I'm going to oh
it's already done I'm gonna sample from
the variational inference distribution
and now we can also train we can also
use the nut sampler with these ad V
estimations so here I'm saying use the
standard deviations as a scaling and
start at the ad V mean parameter
estimates all right so you they're not
necessarily in conflict with one another
you can use either them separately or
you can combine them and sometimes you
get better or worse results alright so
same thing we're gonna see these plots a
lot alright more a trace in this case we
can test our testing set again so the
same thing I did before shared value set
value and now we can sample from the ad
V trace and figure out the accuracy or
we can sample from the nuts trace and
figure out the accuracy there and
hopefully it'll happen pretty quickly
so you can see that the the way you call
the
posterior samplers is the same
regardless of which trace you're using
whether it's an ad v train or ad that's
trace you can just throw it in alright
questions while things are running all
right well I'm gonna have a drink of
water
you guys can entertain yourselves okay
so now you see the problem with using
sampling algorithms in a tutorial as you
often have to spend a lot of time
waiting um so hopefully it'll go it's
the same it's estimating the same
parameters as the MCMC samplers it's
just another technique so you could use
map or ad V or whatever you want yes it
will provide you with the same type of
estimate yes yeah okay all right well
one of them finished 80% accuracy pretty
good for fake data
I guess hopefully the nuts will finish
um so as we're sitting here you can
probably see the nuts takes the Markov
chain Monte Carlo samplers take a lot
longer than add V which is why I don't
use them as much anymore I mostly just
use add V because I don't want to leave
things running for three weeks because
our dev Ops guys get mad when I leave
our AWS thing off that long all right uh
in this case you can see that accuracy
was about the same so we probably could
have gotten away with just using add V
there might be other situations where
you need to use both of them but you can
play around and test ok so we have a
model now a basic logistic regression
one one thing you might need to do at
your job is predict future data and
maybe you want to turn your model into
an API which is something I've done
with PI MC 3 you're not gonna save the
actual model object you won't save this
what you actually want to say it is just
the trace and then you can rebuild your
model later so the trace is the
important part it has all the
information about your sampling so what
you could do is I'm not gonna do it now
but here's the code for it you could
maybe save the trace as a pickle and
then reopen it later and wherever your
API lives you can also use there's a few
different backends available for this I
think you can use sequel Lite and you
could write your own depending on how
big your data is or what your needs are
okay so let's say we want to create some
test data so again we're just randomly
setting some stuff um so because you
don't know the final value you're
predicting it you might think hey I can
just specify the model input because I
don't know the model output Oh too bad
you were wrong for thinking that okay so
you get this weird error about shapes
and the reason seems to me because you
didn't specify an output model an output
value doesn't really make sense to me I
think this is something they're trying
to work on because it you shouldn't have
to put in an observed value if you don't
actually have an observed value but for
now just put in some fake observed data
so in this case I'm going to put in one
as the fake data because the real data
is zero so here you can see that I put
in the fake data as our fake Y and now
everything is working and we're not
getting weird shaped errors okay so now
it's gonna use the trace that you may
have pickled and saved or in this case
just gone from earlier in the notebook
it's gonna use this model that we just
set up and sample from the posterior
again then you can use that the
posterior sample is do you make your
prediction and hopefully it will run
okay I'm gonna start some other stuff
reading because it takes a long time but
I will go over it so well any questions
yeah
um well so this is something you might
use if you're getting in new data and
you know the ex but you don't know the Y
but you want to make a prediction for it
so you've chain trained your data on
some X&Y but now you want to predict
future data yes exactly that's the weird
thing yeah
yes it I agree it's weird I don't know
why it's like that go into our Channel
and ask them this has come up a few
times okay but if you look here we can
see that even though we put in a
predicted value of true it the model has
correctly figured out that the value is
false and so it's change that it gives
us back for addiction of false even that
we put in our prediction is true yeah
yeah for this API version just one let's
see I had 10 features yes sometimes this
takes a super long time I'm sure there
are things you can do to speed it up but
I think it's like these sampling things
just can take a really long time yeah so
you could do a smaller number of samples
if you wanted however many you wanted to
do it maybe there's a I don't yeah I'm
sure there are performance things you
could do okay questions no okay I just
realized I have a lot of time left and
only one example left so you might get
some free time okay so uh the last
example I have is hierarchical logistic
regression it'll look very similar to
the hierarchical linear regression so
again you can set up however many
categories you want in this case I did
for the number of categories that number
observed this should hopefully make
sense again we need to come up with this
list of categories so we can index by
them later will simulate the features
the alphas and the beta's and actual
data and now we have this hierarchical
model so similarly to the hierarchical
linear regression these are really hard
to say we have hyper parameters
that the alphas and betas are drawn from
so conveniently I also called them mu
alpha and nu beta I gave them the same
types of distribution normal and uniform
and again you can see that our alphas
and betas now have means of MU alpha and
mu beta and the same thing again we have
the the number of alphas we have is the
same as the number of categories and
then ever a betas we have to estimate
now is a number of categories and the
number by the number of features ok any
questions about that alright so I
started running ad V but because this is
a more complicated model we have more
data it's probably gonna take a long
time so yeah and you won't have
questions while we're waiting for things
to sample yeah
uh I have no idea I haven't done time
varying parameter estimates does it what
else now at the Beth that seems
plausible yeah uh I think a lot of it is
from Theon oh so I don't know if they've
I don't know somebody's working on Theon
oh right probably I don't know they seem
pretty fast the time see three people
seem really fast at responding to errors
so maybe it'll get better I know like
this API thing where you had to put in
fake data is something they're working
on they have a whole bunch of open
issues and they're super faster
responding maybe I don't know I haven't
looked into all of that stuff I haven't
needed to do as much performance
enhancement things yes I'm pretty sure
there are I also have not used that but
I definitely know there's some stuff
about chains
yeah I think it's just faster well
that's the reason I use it I don't know
if there are other reasons I know they
did the people who created ad V designed
it to be more of a black box so I think
part of it is maybe you don't have to
understand all the nuances that you
might have to do with samplers and like
all the decisions you can make with
sampling but I recommend you just try it
and see if it works for you yeah well
usually you know the number of
categories because the data will be
labeled in some way so like that iris
data set that's in scikit-learn has
three categories and you know that at my
job we have data that comes from
different markets so I know the number
of markets and I know there's gonna be
differences in markets I think you'd
have to use something else if you were
trying to discover the number of
categories but yeah yeah yes
no you need to already know what the
category is okay so maybe the iris one
was a slightly poor example so this
isn't if you're trying to figure out
what category it is it's if the category
is a feature of your data yes yeah so
then you would pull out the categories
as this list of categories and it would
no longer be a direct feature but you
would get to it by indexing the
appropriate alphas and betas
try it you can do whatever you want yeah
so you don't have to use samplers for
hierarchical models it's just easier
because it's more or less out of the box
so that's why I started using this
library I'm sure you could do all the
math and analytically do something in
some cases
it depends on your data but it I think
it will it will definitely change the
amount of time it takes to converge so
you might find that if your standard
deviation is really wrong you'll have to
it'll take longer to converge um or you
can just test a few different values of
it so yes it can mess things up
but not irreparable II okay yeah so
things are gonna take a while um yeah I
didn't realize it would take this long a
good thing I still have a lot of time
left so um we can stand here and watch
this try and converge or you guys could
keep asking questions you can walk
around whatever you want um
so eventually this should keep running
hopefully it's happening on yours as
well um one thing I wanted to note is if
we ever get to the point where this is
sampling if you accidentally specify
like 20,000 or 200,000 samples you can
actually stop your sampling in the
middle and you'll still be able to use
your trace it'll just be however much
you're using and you can still do the
trace plots and summaries and all that
stuff will still work
um well we are trying to use it in
production at shift geek right now I
think as you mentioned the tres even
just sampling for one data point can
take a long time so we're sort of
weighing weighing the options you could
just take the means and standard
deviations and just use those as a point
estimate and just do the training I like
the idea of doing the sampling and sort
of having a better idea of how good our
estimate is so we'll see what DevOps has
to say and how much they can help me and
what my boss thinks I don't think so I
think it's just an array it might have
some more information in it I don't I'm
not sure anything else uh yeah I mean
this is as much as I know about the Otto
ya know you'll get into all these weird
errors and hopefully somebody else will
have solved them like me or you spend a
lot of time on stackoverflow trying to
figure out why these errors happened
yeah I still don't understand thing I
know that much I probably should know
more uh but you know it's hard when your
boss is like get something out
I would like tomorrow no more Theon Oh
someone wants to give a tutorial on that
please do okay yeah so this is just good
to see Apple uh so right now I'm doing
add V and then I was gonna feed that
into a nut um I yam on other problems I
have this is the add V that's taking a
long time because the data is more
complicated and I conveniently put in a
version without add V but forgot to use
that one so cool well that was a lot
shorter than I thought it'd be
that's why I used it I knew I wanted
something hierarchical and as far as I
can tell there's not that many other
existing libraries that'll let you do it
that easily
obviously pie Stan could use it but yeah
I think it's just if you have to build
more complicated models if you like
doing Bayesian modeling if you have a
lot of prior knowledge that you want to
put in you should use it did you have a
question should I imagine you raising
your hand okay yeah uh there on my
github repo can you see that yeah yeah
probably sorry I don't know I haven't
written a customs death method but I
would be surprised if they had taken
that out I think they liked the idea of
you being able to write custom step
methods and backends and stuff so hey
it's almost running okay yeah like I
said there's another version of the
notebook that doesn't have any of the
errors in it so if you want to be able
to just pull code out and not run into
the errors I suggest you use that one
instead but in all these blocks that I
wrote where I was doing the code twice I
put in comments showing where I changed
things so if you need to see where the
error arose I just look for these change
comments oh okay cool so this elbow
doesn't look as great a double elbow
it looks like it's converging it's good
enough
so hopefully the nuts sampler will start
but this will also take a long time
because it's sampling yeah so this is
was my life for like three months was
just waiting for things to sample and
then every day my scrum update would be
it's still running and my
the VP of Product was like what does
that mean and I was like Oh sampling
works too worried about it
luckily he did not know any better so
couldn't argue yeah okay yeah like I
said this is all I have it was I must
have spoken more quickly than I thought
it would so you guys get an extra-long
break you chose the right tutorial